from a stunning Irish fairy tale to a
terrifying Korean horror flick these
movie masterpieces had their 100 Rotten
Tomato scores tarnished by a single bad
review Curtis Hansen's 1997 crime epic
LA Confidential is a Timeless classic
based on James elroy's acclaims neo-nor
novel of the same name it's an intricate
merciless and sharp adaptation that
examines murder and corruption in 1950s
Los Angeles Through The Eyes of three
vastly different police officers Edmund
Exley played by Guy Pierce is an honest
LAPD Sergeant trying to follow in his
late Father's Footsteps and avenge him
after his murder by an unknown killer
Russell Crowe's Bud white is the
opposite he's a brood of a cop with a
hatred towards men who hurt women and
he's not afraid to act on it worst of
all is Jack Vincennes creepily portrayed
by Kevin Spacey a sergeant at the
narcotics Department who'd sell his own
mother out for a buck exploiting his
authority he specializes in high-profile
celebrity arrests and receives tips
regularly from the local tabloid
magazine run by Danny DeVito's sleazy
publisher as the paths of these men
cross they get entangled in some
intricate cases they go higher up in the
Hollywood hierarchy than any of them
could imagine you want to tear all that
down
with a wrecking ball
I'm gonna help me swing it with the
resting performances on all counts a
death script and an intoxicating look at
the Los Angeles of yesteryear LA
Confidential is a rare cinematic Triumph
while one critic found the pacing
frustrating many others praised the Slow
Burn approach of the film something that
pays tribute to the many noir films that
inspired it despite its impressive score
on Rotten Tomatoes CES Gay's 2015 comedy
drama Truman isn't a movie you see on
many best of lists but it probably
should be Truman follows two lifelong
friends Julian and Tomas as the latter
flies in from Canada to Spain to visit
his best friend for One Last Time Julian
has terminal stage lung cancer and the
treatments haven't been working so he
has decided to enjoy the little time he
has left before the joy leaves his life
for good respecting his decision Tomas
accompanies him for four days as he
finds a guardian for his lovely dog
Truman chooses a casket for his own
funeral and celebrates his son's
birthday in Amsterdam the film
poignantly conveys the beauty of
friendship death and saying goodbye to
life with dignity and Grace despite its
heavy and emotional subject matter
Truman finds thoughtful and uplifting
moments in the most mundane things of
everyday life conveying intimacy and
love and unexpected and rewarding ways
it's no surprise that most critics
couldn't resist its charm however a
single one felt that it didn't quite
strike the right balance in tone leaving
the film just shy of a perfect score on
Rotten Tomatoes David McKenzie's 2013
prison drama startup is a modern cold
classic for a reason it features Jack
O'Connell and Ben mendelsohn at their
absolute best while also delivering an
accurate explicit and realistic
depiction of prison life in the UK
unsurprisingly the movie garnered
several Award nominations including for
the baftas and the British independent
film Awards
foreign
ER the plot follows young criminal Eric
love who's moved from a juvenile
Penitentiary to a high security adult
prison where his father Neville is
serving a life sentence although the two
have a tumultuous and emotionally
distant relationship Neville does
everything he can to convince his son to
follow the rules and prevent him from
making stupid mistakes that could leave
him with a similar fate he's not the
only one looking out for Eric's
well-being though Oliver a prison
therapist who runs a group for young
criminal offenders is also trying to
help Eric with his traumas in an effort
to rehabilitate him however Eric's wild
side and violent outbursts put his
future freedom in doubt tragic
empathetic and fierce startup deserves
all the accolades given by critics its
exclusion from The 100 Club doesn't
change how highly regarded It Is song of
the sea a delightful 2014 animated
Adventure was swooned over by critics
and viewers for the way it combines
Irish folklore with beautiful hand-drawn
visuals and a touching story as a
co-production of several European
filmmakers the film is rich in culture
and has a distinctive atmosphere so it's
no surprise it's been recognized by
several award organizations like the
Oscars of eventually winning a satellite
award and the European film Award for
best animated feature the plot follows
an Irish boy Ben his father Conor and
his sister sirsha who live in a
lighthouse on an island off the coast of
Ireland it's a broken family however the
children's Mother brona disappeared
after she gave birth to sirsha on
sirce's sixth birthday their grandmother
arrives and convinces Connor to move to
the city saying it would be better for
the kids to grow up there after some
consideration the father agrees and once
they move to the mainland Ben and sircea
find themselves entangled in a magical
mission that involves fairies spirits
and other Celtic creatures who
desperately need their help the second
movie in Tom Moore's Irish folklore
Trilogy which also includes the Secret
of Kells and wolf Walkers received
almost comprehensive praise from critics
it seems there's little to critique
about this charming film but it didn't
speak to everyone the one discordant
review suggests that the characters were
not as fleshed out as they could have
been based on the critical consensus the
1974 neo-nor Chinatown is one of the
greatest films of all time whether you
like the movie or not you simply can't
ignore its prestigious qualities which
include a smart and layered screenplay
excellent acting and an atmospheric
score by Jerry Goldsmith surprisingly
however one of the naysayers of this
all-time great was the legendary Chicago
Tribune film critics Gene Siskel famous
for his sharp and well-arged criticisms
Siskel never tried to hide it when he
didn't like a popular film that almost
everyone else did including his friend
and colleague Roger Ebert besides
Chinatown Cisco also had some harsh
words to say about iconic flicks such as
The Big Lebowski Thelma and Louise and
Silverado gee Lou I'm doing the best I
can Chinatown Stars Jack Nicholson as
private eye JJ giddis who's hired by A
peculiar woman played by Faye Dunaway to
investigate whether or not her husband
is cheating on her this seemingly simple
case sends gitis down a road of
corruption deception and murder as he
finds himself increasingly involved and
determined to figure out how the clues
lead to some of the most powerful men in
Los Angeles Chinatown Was nominated for
11 Oscars including best picture best
director and best cinematography but it
only took home a single one for its
original screenplay even after all these
years the late Gene Cisco is still the
only dissenting voice on this film
according to Rotten Tomatoes something
that's definitely an achievement itself
creating a successful wave of South
Korean Horrors no Hong Jin's 2016
feature the Wei Ling double down on
murder mystery and Chaos like his
earlier similarly gripping movies the
Chaser and the Yellow Sea the whaling
was successful both critically and
commercially it was a certified box
office hit making nearly 50 million
dollars on a relatively small 6 million
dollar budget this terrifying story
takes place in a tiny South Korean
Village in the mountains a bizarre
disease has broken out and started
infecting the locals Who inexplicably
start to go berserk and eventually slay
their own families policeman jong-goo is
put on the case to investigate these
devastating and strange occurrences but
as he digs deeper into what's happening
things unravel in bloody and unsettling
ways in a journey that includes shamans
spirits and supernatural creatures
explanations arrive from the places we
least expect despite a single negative
review claiming that the narrative
doesn't justify the long run time of 2
hours and 36 minutes most critics raved
about the whaling leaving it with a firm
99 approval rating on Rotten Tomatoes
Alan Elliott and Sidney Pollock's music
documentary Amazing Grace is a
phenomenal film that suffered from a
myriad of legal problems until it was
finally released in 2018. the movie
presents footage of Aretha Franklin
recording her famous gospel album
Amazing Grace in front of a live
audience at the new Temple Missionary
Baptist Church in Los Angeles in 1972.
it wasn't released at the time due to
Technical and synchronizing issues and
it sat in a Warner Brothers Vault for
years until Elliot bought the rights
after he repaired and edited the tape he
planned to release it in 2011 but that
never happened because Franklin sued him
for appropriating her likeness without
permission and again in 2015 for
undisclosed reasons after she died in
2018 the singer's niece Sabrina Owens
watched the completed documentary and
came to an agreement with Elliot
approving its release on behalf of the
estate many of you who never had the
opportunity to hear Aretha
sing gospel
you're in tonight for a great thrill the
87 minute long compilation of footage
features legendary musicians like James
Cleveland Cornell Dupree Chuck Rainey
and more after is more widely screened
the movie quickly gathered a vastly
positive reception from critics and
viewers the Raw Talent of Franklin is at
the center of this documentary but one
negative reviewer felt that it missed
some opportunities to really get to the
heart of her Artistry with a unique
Melancholy Vibe the 2018 drama ashes
purest white distinguishes itself from
other films in its genre part gangster
movie part tragic love story while
leaning more towards the latter it has
none of the trademark characteristics
usually employed in genre films of this
kind this quality definitely elevates
the picture as a pure and original
Chinese movie and it might be why most
critics took to it so unanimously except
for one of course the plot tells the
story of a 16-year-long romance between
Chao a local girl from a poor Chinese
neighborhood and Ben a mob boss in the
city of datang the movie shows how the
two go from respected and feared figures
in their Community to Penny lists and
disgrace nobody is rejected by Society
it's a slow transformation as viewers
watch them go through incarcer
restoration and several life changes
that gradually destroy their
relationship and the love that once
burned in them for each other although
directors romantic crime epic didn't do
particularly well at the box office it
was nominated for multiple prestigious
Awards and garnered almost Universal
praise from critics even the single
negative review praised the
cinematography lead performances and
moving storyline but felt the long run
time dragged it down the 2018 HBO drama
the tale directed by Jennifer Fox is a
bold and risky take on one of the most
difficult topics out there the sexual
abuse of children the result is a film
that is as thought provoking raw and
uncomfortable as it is disturbing the
story is based on Fox's own experiences
growing up now she dealt with the
repercussions as an adult Laura Dern
stars as Jennifer a successful
documentary filmmaker one day she
receives a phone call from her worried
mother who says that she found an essay
she wrote when she was 13. the details
of sexual relationship with her
middle-aged writing instructor and
running coach forced to recall her faded
memories Jennifer goes down a painful
Rabbit Hole to investigate what happened
to her all those years ago faced with
the uncomfortable truth she decides to
confront the individuals who took
advantage of her naivety and youth the
tale is a harrowing and Unapologetic
film that highlights how our minds can
rewrite painful memories to Shield us
from devastating truths we have trouble
coping with it's one of the main reasons
critics praised the movie so highly with
the only nitpick being that it feels
like a TV movie which being an HBO
original it is even the exception to the
positive reviews concedes that the cast
is exceptional and performances from
Dern Elizabeth Debicki Ellen Burston and
the young Isabel nalis carry the weight
of the heavy material I'm not the victim
of this story anything you
think I'm the hero if you or anyone you
know has been a victim of sexual assault
help is available visit the rape abuse
and incest National Network website or
contact Reigns National helpline at
1-800-656 Hope 4673